.
HAPPY ANNIVERSARY.
>> Jesse: THANK YOU.
>> Mike: GOOD EVENING FROM
WASHINGTON.
I'M MIKE EMANUEL IN FOR BRET
BAIER.
WE ARE COVERING A NUMBER OF BIG
STORIES.
THE DEATH RATE IS RISING AT THE
SITE OF THE COLLAPSE CONDO
TOWERS IN SOUTH FLORIDA.
MUCH OF THAT STATE IS BRACING
FOR WHAT COULD BE DAMAGING RAIN
AND WINDS FROM TROPICAL STORM
POSSIBLY HURRICANE HE WILL.
IS A PRESIDENT BIDEN IS URGING
AMERICANS WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
VACCINATED TO TAKE THE SHOT AND
SAYS THE DELTA VARIANT OF THE
CORONAVIRUS MAY BE MORE
DANGEROUS THAN THE ORIGINAL.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH AMERICA'S
CRIME CRISIS A BLOODY FOURTH OF
JULY WEEKEND AND AT LEAST 267
PEOPLE KILLED IN SHOOTING
INCIDENTS.
IN CHICAGO, 18 PEOPLE WERE
KILLED IN SHOOTINGS INVOLVING AT
LEAST 100 PEOPLE.
POLICE SAY IN NEARLY ALL THE
INCIDENTS, NO SUSPECTS WERE
TAKEN INTO CUSTODY.
IN CLEVELAND, 11 PEOPLE WERE
SHOT IN A FIVE-HOUR PERIOD.
8 PEOPLE WERE KILLED IN
PHILADELPHIA, WITH 27 OTHERS
HURT.
DENVER POLICE REPORTED FIVE
SEPARATE SHOOTINGS WITHIN A
FOUR-HOUR PERIOD.
IN NEW YORK, EMBATTLED GOVERNOR
ANDREW CUOMO IS TAKING A DRASTIC
STEP DUE TO THE GROWING GUN
VIOLENCE.
CORRESPONDENT BRYAN LLENAS
REPORTS TONIGHT FROM TIMES
SQUARE.
GOOD EVENING, BRIAN.
BRYAN.>> NEW YORK IN A STATE OF
EMERGENCY.
THE TREAT GUN VIOLENCE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS.
THE GOVERNOR NOTING TODAY OVER
THE JULY 4TH WEEKEND MORE PEOPLE
DIED FROM SHOOTINGS IN HIS STATE
THAN FROM COVID-19.
>> SO TODAY, FIRST STATE IN THE
NATION IS GOING TO DECLARE A
DISASTER EMERGENCY ON GUN
VIOLENCE.
>> GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO
DECLARING A STATE OF EMERGENCY,
A MOVE THAT WILL COMMIT MORE
MONEY TO COMBATING WHAT HE CALLS
AN EPIDEMIC OF GUN VIOLENCE.
[SIREN]
>> SHOOTINGS IN NEW YORK CITY
ARE UP 42% COMPARED TO LAST
YEAR.
INCLUDING BRAZEN AND RANDOM
ATTACKS IN TIMES SQUARE AND ON
SIDEWALKS IN BROAD DAYLIGHT.
26 PEOPLE WERE SHOT IN TWO DOZEN
SHOOTINGS THIS WEEKEND ALONE.
>> ABOUT 50% OF OUR SHOOTINGS
ARE GANG RELATED RIGHT NOW AND
WE ALSO HAVE AN INCREASE IN
RETALIATORY SHOOTING WHEN PERSON
OR TWO PEOPLE SHOT THEN SOMEONE
FROM THAT SIDE IS NOW
RETALIATING.
>> THE ATF LET FOX NEWS INTO
THEIR NEW YORK CITY GUN VAULT
WHERE ROW AFTER ROW OF
CONFISCATED RIFLES AND HANDGUNS
ARE STORED FROM CRIME SEQUENCE
SCATTERED NATIONWIDE.
WORKING TOGETHER TO COMBAT GUN
VIOLENCE.
>> THIS IS THE WHOLE CITY RIGHT
NOW.
>> FOX NEWS RECEIVED AN
EXCLUSIVE LOOK INSIDE THEIR NEW
SHARED HEADQUARTERS WHERE AGENTS
ARE USING A NEW ANALYTIC
DASHBOARD TO SEAMLESSLY SHARE
INTEL IN REALTIME.
GUNS RECOVERED FROM CRIME
SCENES, SHOOTING INVESTIGATIONS
AND SHOOTING DEATHS.
IT'S AN UNPRECEDENTED EFFORT TO
GET GUNS USED TO COMMIT CRIMES
OFF THE STREETS WHILE
IDENTIFYING GUN TRAFFICKERS.
THEY HOPE THIS WILL BE A MODEL
FOR CITIES NATIONWIDE.
>> RAPID TRACING OF BALLISTICS
TO MAKE SURE SOMEBODY GETS
CAUGHT WITH A GUN, IF THAT GUN
WAS USED IN A PRIOR SHOOTING, WE
ARE ABLE TO RAPIDLY CONNECT IT
TO THAT PRIOR CRIME SCENE SO WE
CAN HOLD THOSE PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> WHEN A FIREARM IS RECOVERED
WE SUBMIT IT FOR TRACING AND WE
GET THE RESULTS IN A MATTER OF A
WEEK TO 10 DAYS USED TO BE MUCH
LONGER TIME SPAN.
>> THE NYPD MADE 2300 GUN
ARRESTS SO FAR THIS YEAR.
THAT'S 39% INCREASE COMPARED TO
LAST YEAR.
NYPD COMMISSIONER DERMOT SHAE
SAYS THE PROBLEM IS 83% OF THOSE
ARRESTED ON GUN CHARGES ARE
RELEASED BACK ONTO THE STREETS.
HE BLAMES IN PART THE CITY'S
BAIL REFORM LAW PASSED IN 201